hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alva
I'm John Humphrey
we're gonna watch two endgame related
videos one is this TV spot called
mission only 30 seconds long and then
the other one is gonna be aldo jones
weird trailer number three for Avengers
four it's gonna watch them back-to-back
algorithm and let it not if you look
over here you'll see a box in the
background that box is there because we
have to be moved out of this place by
the end of April so with endgame Game of
Thrones and all the other movies and
trails and stuff it's gonna be a crazy
month to keep up with YouTube and
patreon whilst packing packing really
late last night they bought the bendings
this month just as little heads-up it
may be at the last life for the first
like three days in May we might not be
uploading or we might have videos
prepped in advance but if we're not on
top of things and the last two days of
April or the first three days of May
that is why just go through the reaction
already well some people want an
explanation okay some people are gonna
want a heads up some people watch this
channel regularly let's get to it
let's start with Mission Avengers
missionary it's a good position the best
[Applause]
[Music]
mistakes
new footage yeah
[Laughter]
they're doing the Shazam hands in
they're gonna say grace together it's
all it's all trailer manipulation
definitely and none of that's in the
movie way no should I clarify I'm joking
or just no people no no yeah their
response they can understand that
they're there you're smart and they're
gonna put it together I half-expected
rocket to be like oh we're all just
standing in a circle like a bunch of
eighties like so much or whatever the
light into the galaxy it looks like
awkwardly skinny here doesn't mean yeah
Evans he does he says it's kind of a
little aged or something yeah it looks
like whatever time-lapse has happened
within the course of the endgame because
it you know it seems like pretty
apparent there's gonna be a certain
chunk of then there's gonna be another
jumper whatever you know I don't know
you've done several breakdown videos is
a 30-second spot we're not really gonna
do a whole bunch of breaking down here
but I like how when he's saying that
even Tony he's looking Tony's looking
over and like another one of these it
looks like
Roden and BlackWidow or like yeah we're
with you into this but I love how they
even kept that vibe of ant-man still
like yeah who really loved Captain
America yeah excited speed part of the
team or even area keeping that theme
going from civil war even rocket even
you know acknowledging the greatness of
that added you know one of those
theories that that's shot in one of
those trailers where rocket is on war
machine shoulder that that might be
trailer manipulation but they had
another moment here where it's probably
out of the same sequence falling open
still trailer it's still trailer
misspending cgi characters and they're
gonna spend millions and mislead us this
whole quantum you know sequence is
making me wonder now too because you
know that was one of the big scenes you
theorized was you know but heavily
manipulated from the last you know full
trailer and it does look like tony is
there in this moment well wait a minute
okay how many fists are going in here
nine
including rockets okay so let's count
here it's kind of got one at man grown
rocket wrote in and BlackWidow as for
right yes for Captain America Tony Tony
does the people he cuts you and then the
other shot you had a war machine or
machine yeah nebula yeah this is cool
tickets now on sale more like all
tickets are sold out for the next four
weeks yeah good luck appreciate that
guys it's worms all right well let's
move on let's go to uh let's do the fun
one now the weird trailer by Aldo Jones
I know you like to do your patron shout
outs and stuff and yadda yadda yadda
we're gonna probably pause it at that
point it's just saying now but we'll
talk about your weird trailer Aldo Oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
okay I actually really like the way you
edited this dude putting him in there
this is how we should do ours see you
guys know the most people we reject our
mobile apps so we actually agree to them
because we like quite a few
Karina diet
[Music]
you did a preview first Brede yeah I
don't know trailers were evolved into
the times
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
I don't really have a lot to say about
it this weird trailer because you know
we usually love breaking down your weird
trailers dude they're kind of on time
crunch every day now I was genuinely
hooked when Thor was texting captain
realizing how much I want to see a
romance the two there was a moment there
where I was like what's she gonna say oh
it's gonna just be a joke and this is
funny you know but I was genuinely like
ooh like it's this is a relatable
situation for a man right now oh yeah
especially after Jane and everything and
oh the insert of the mixing in with the
Aladdin spot was so smart do you trust
me do you trust me you got a smart
[Applause]
that's that kind of joke exactly one of
those references and they I mean you
know there's just so many trailers it's
hard to draw the lines between them and
that's why we have although jumpin look
like asses take it up with pizza from
his shield this was one of the more
random feeling ones in a while which was
very fun to me because it's yeah you
just got like Whoopi Goldberg walking
through the framing at Santa Clara died
you got this pizza dude thank you so
more people need to watch santa clarita
diet that is one of the best comedies on
TV right now
I ever there's three seasons in every
single season is wonderful I love that
show so once I saw it I'm like yes it's
getting love yes anyway great job aldo
super proud of you buddy
before we wrap this up I get a quick
page from the day shots a man named
totally jumbled he's actually visiting
l.a around the time we're gonna go see
endgame he hit us up he wants to go so
he ended up getting himself a ticket at
our theater
teeth so he's gonna go watch endgame
with us dude he played your cards right
and then I cut a hole at the bottom of
my popcorn bucket you could have as much
popcorn as you want
patron exclusive
popcorn treats yeah mickey rourke diner
did he do something oh yeah sorry movie
channel I figured it out and pull out a
movie reference to a very topical film
starring whiplash in Iron Man 2 related
if I spin it that way everybody go watch
diner
anyway TJ I heard your daughter was sick
quit hitting her it doesn't make you a
good dad can't wait to hang out with you
soon buddy subscribe to the reject
nation click that notification bell see
you got soup